would you rather be a guard or prisoner
I don't think I look while it used to be
a guard prisoner prisoner a guy's
prisoner sounds like you would be a
little less work prisoner why is that
nobody likes cars good afternoon
gentlemen
this experiment will be an extension my
research into the effects prisons can
have on human behavior you're gonna be
pleased to know that you all have been
chosen to be the prison guards but one
are no circumstances whatsoever a unit
physically assault the prisoners in any
way so remember just as you were
watching the prisoners my graduate staff
and I will be watching you all right
gentlemen we all have ourselves a I'm
fine rule number one prisoners must
remain silent this is an exercise period
okay is it just me or do these guys
taking this thing a bit too seriously
why don't you give me 20 push-ups
really this guy thinks he's John Wayne
or something you addressed me as mr.
correctional officer
this might be an interesting
two weeks after all why don't you make
up your bunk eight six one two I did mr.
correctional officer
well that's not what I see hey what are
you doing what was that
should we step in no let the cards
figure it out let's see where it goes
evening gentlemen how about we make this
one a night to remember this is all real
they won't let you go they won't let us
leave those are not prisoners those are
not subjects those are boys and you are
harming them is that what you thought
was gonna be I had no idea would turn
out this way